this is why bitcoin in canada matters
throughout february truckers have been
protesting the government's injection
mandate i'm going to be careful with the
words i use in order to stop these
freedom fighting and largely peaceful
protesters the government implemented
the emergencies act which is actually
reserved for terrorists this means the
government can freeze the bank account
of protesters and those who donated as a
result people started using bitcoin
because it's outside of the traditional
system now the canadian government is
asking all crypto companies to freeze
funds and addresses this includes
centralized exchanges to which the ceo
of one of those exchanges advised people
to withdraw their funds as they will be
forced to comply when you withdraw your
funds into a non-custodial wallet it's
non-confiscatable and cannot be frozen
bitcoin is the most empowering type of
money immune from government corruption
as a result canada is now investigating
whether ceo's encouraging this
withdrawal is illegal absolute
authoritarian clown world